[Applaudissements]
à bruxelles après un mois de débats
difficiles qui ont voué deux experts à
la crise cardiaque les ministres de
l'agriculture des six sont parvenus à un
accord cet accord ouvrira dès juillet un
marché de 160 millions de clients aux
agriculteurs des six pays ils mettent en
action la deuxième étape du marché comme
un prévue par le traité de rome
[Musique]
neige froid et tempêtes les deux tiers
des états unis ont suivi l'assaut de la
masse d'air glacé venus du canada le
plus rigoureux enregistré depuis le
début du siècle - 22 à denver dans le
colorado où l'élégance s'adapte au froid
les enfants eux ont mis au point un
nouveau jeu
[Musique]
il reste que les palmiers d'atlanta
géorgie ont paru tout à coup déplacer
dans le paysage un peu partout le trafic
est devenu quasiment impossible et la
circulation a été coupée sauf exception
qui confirme la règle
un hiver rigoureux dans les régions les
plus ensoleillées ont cette fois porté
la marque
[Musique]
en angleterre le trident a remis un peu
de chaleur dans les coeurs britannique
cousin de la caravelle à la mode de
grande bretagne il en a adopté des
réacteurs à l'arrière du fuselage le
nouvel appareil a fait ses premiers pas
si l'on peut dire devant sergio frais de
la viande et quelques 6000 spectateurs
capable de transporter une centaine de
passagers à 960 km heure on compte
beaucoup sur lui au pays de shakespeare
pour effacer les échecs successifs des
malheureux connect
où
en inde la conjoncture astrale de ce
début d'année à jeter dans la
consternation les brahmanes et les
fakirs qui ont appelé les fidèles à la
prière depuis pour conjurer le mauvais
sort il prit réunis à la nouvelle des
vides dans une noix de coco fruits qui
permet de se concilier les faveurs
divines et jade sans désemparer du
beurre fondu dans les flammes la
combinaison des planètes et elle en
effet que de graves événements peuvent
être imminent pareil combinaison
n'avait-elle pas amener voici huit cents
ans une invasion du pays et quelque
temps plus tôt il y a cinq mille ans
n'avait-elle pas déjà provoqué une
guerre désastreuse alors les fakirs prix
pour conjurer le sort et sans doute
sont-ils fondés à croire en l'efficacité
de leurs actions pour peu qu il la
compare à celle de la diplomatie
internationale
oh
[Musique]
ya dix ans disparaissait le maréchal de
lattre de tassigny
de lattre de tassigny vous vous souvenez
on n'a pas oublié les scènes qui
jalonnèrent scène le 16 août 1944 le
pavillon du général de lattre flottait
en vue des côtes de provence les troupes
placées sous ses ordres devenue la
première armée française en tanet la
marche victorieuse qui allait les
conduire sans désemparer jusqu'en alsace
[Musique]
et dans colmar delattre recevait le
baiser d'une province libéré
le 31 mars 45 avec un matériel de
fortune leur a été franchi et quelques
mois après les nuits étaient bas les
armes et capitulait
[Musique]
c'était alors l'arrivée à l'improviste
delattre près de montgomery eisenhower
et joukov imposant la présence française
à l'armistice de berlin
d'autres images montrent du passé un
jour aux invalides on avait vu un père
salué la dépouille de son fils qu'il
avait décoré lui même en indochine
enfin l'heure où soulac de l'étoile
le président de la république déposa sur
son cercueil le bâton de maréchal ou la
france rendait hommage au grand soldat
qu'il avait bien servi de notre dame aux
invalides à travers paris le général
eisenhower le maréchal montgomery
avaient accompagné leurs compagnons de
lutte avec les généraux français les
membres du gouvernement et des corps
constitués
il y a de cela 10 en disant qu'ils
peuvent suffire peut-être pour oublier
mais qui n'empêche pas de se souvenir
[Applaudissements]
face à la célèbre colline de fourvière
de l'autre côté de la saône c'est le
vieux lion trop vieux même puisque dans
la rue mercière qui fut la plus passante
de lyon au moyen-âge des magasins fermés
annonce des démolitions prochaine tout
un quartier usé par le temps va en effet
disparaître et qui songerait à regretter
ces maisons l'épreuve et pourtant et
pourtant le quai saint-antoine c'est
aussi au milieu des rideaux de fer
aujourd'hui tirer une enseigne une
enseigne qui porte le nom d'une aventure
ici naquit guignols vers la fin du
xviiie siècle depuis lors sans doute il
avait conquis la france mais il était
resté fidèle à son théâtre chargé de
dorures du quai saint-antoine
[Musique]
certes les marionnettes que laurent
mourguet sculpta en 1800 milliard francs
le savetier bachique madelon les pouces
truculente et le plus célèbre de tous
guignol ne sont plus aujourd'hui que des
pièces de musée
certes la salle ne connais plus
aujourd'hui que des assistants enfantine
mais guignols continue sa vie de théâtre
entre les mains vigilante de son actuel
animateur ernest neige aux airs 80 ans
il s'est acquis de nouveaux partenaires
ernest neige aux airs lui même mais
aussi d'autres et non des moindres
edouard herriot charles de gaulle
en plus d'un siècle et demi le
répertoire n'a cessé de son côté de
s'enrichir les valeurs vallée du début
voisines et vers les années 25 au milieu
de trois cents pièces diverses avec
faust et l'on compte aujourd'hui un
guignol parachutistes superproduction
bien sûr américano lyonnaise par le quai
saint-antoine disparaîtra il faudra
quand même regretter le théâtre de
morgen inaki guignols
ces trois points marqués par l'écossé
smith à la 15e minute du match du
tournoi des six nations opposant les
cosses maillot blanc à la france sur le
terrain demeurent et fils ont donné le
frisson à tous les supporteurs français
à ce moment les écossais dominé leurs
adversaires de la tête et des épaules
égalisation inespérée de la france sur
coup-franc également 15 minutes plus
tard
deuxième mi temps malgré quelques rares
attaques françaises les avants écossais
domine toujours le match
et pourtant c'est la france qui prend
l'avantagé encore sur coup franc tiré
une nouvelle fois par albaladejo le demi
d'ouverture ce second coup de pied
inespéré fait basculer le match en
faveur des français
toutes les attaques écossaise échoué par
manque d'imagination alors que celle de
l'équipe de france improvisé pour la
plupart sème la panique chez leurs
adversaires
et c'est une de ces attaques qui se
termine par le magnifique essai de
rancoule que transforme albaladejo 11 à
3 l'équipe de france a bien commencé
dans ce tournoi 62e qu'elle peut gagner
comme celui de l'an dernier
[Musique]